selvi c'est bien la première fois que
vous me voyez en short dans une vidéo
vous allez sûrement entendre des bruits
de percussion de musique car
j'enregistre cette vidéo le jour de la
fête de la musique
et pourquoi ça fait déjà neuf jours
simplement parce que dans la prochaine
semaine j'enchaîne avec la fin de la
tournée du spectacle et la suite des
dédicaces
alors le but de cette vidéo c'est de
vous dire ce qui va se passer cet été
sur la chaîne et par extension à la
rentrée vous révèle tout ça à la fin de
la vidéo premier point pourquoi cette
vidéo elle sort un vendredi à 17h30
alors j'avais annoncé samedi 11h
simplement parce que cette année je vous
avais dit dans la vidéo du 1er janvier
que je n'aurai pas de rythme
contrairement à l'année dernière où j'ai
publié une vidéo chaque jour c'est pas
tout à fait exact car si vous avez des
attentes si vous avez vu que je faisais
dix vidéos par mois
quelle que soit la durée du mois est
donc là on est fin juin c'est la dixième
vidéo de juin et c'est la 60e vidéo
depuis le début de cette année ensuite
et je vous donne le programme après j'ai
fait un partenariat sur la chaîne en
début de semaine dernière c'était le
premier sur les 426 vidéo qui existe sur
cette chaîne et je n'avais pas prévu de
vous en parler puis suite aux
commentaires je me suis bossu ce couple
compan parler vite fait le premier truc
à prendre en compte c'est que si j'en ai
fait qu'un seul sur 426 vidéo c'est pas
parce qu'on n'a pas proposé c'est parce
que je sélectionne quelque chose de
cohérent quelque chose qui ait du sens
pour vous quelque chose qui peut vous
intéresser
et quelque chose en lien avec un sujet
de vidéos que j'ai envie de faire à la
base et c'était le cas de cette vidéo
vous verrez que si vous enlevez toute la
partie partenariat elle tient debout de
la même manière vous m'avez demandé s'il
y en aura d'autres oui j'en sais rien
peut-être en tout cas une chose est sûre
c'est que je n'ouvrirai jamais de type i
je ne ferai jamais d'appel aux dons sur
la chaîne et quand même une logique
économique si vous voulez plus de choses
et je ne veux pas recevoir de dons des
abonnés j'aime pas ce concept moi
personnellement je dis pas que c'est pas
bien pour les autres je dis que ça me
correspond pas ça me met pas à l'aise
donc les partenariats s'ils sont faits
de manière cool et créative avec des
bonnes personnes je trouve ça
intéressant et le dernier truc sur les
partenariats
enlevez vous le fantasme de la tête des
trucages or dix mille euros ou 15000
euros j'en sais rien ce n'est pas la
réalité c'est pas le cas dans les
propositions comme pure bref on est bien
en france ce n'est pas grave de faire
des partenariats tout va bien alors cet
été il va se passer quoi déjà dans un
premier temps j'espère qu'il y aura plus
de bruit dans la rue et dans un deuxième
temps pour comprendre ce qui va se
passer cet été pour que je vous parle de
la rentrée à la rentrée va y avoir une
sorte de relance de la chaîne c'est
quelque chose que j'avais fait le 1er
janvier de cette année c'est quelque
chose que j'avais fait le 1er septembre
également de l'année dernier par relance
j'entends me posait tout mettre à plat
me re organisé retrouver un planning
retrouver un projet est toujours dans le
mentalisme
comment je m'organisais ce que je peux
pas faire d'autres vidéos des deux
dernières fois quand j'ai fait ça ça m'a
motivé à mort et ça s'est senti sur la
chaîne et ça s'est senti aussi doit
traiter par rapport au nombre d'abonnés
qui nous ont rejoints salut les gars et
les filles où nombre de vues de la
chaîne à l'interaction et quand je
lisais vos commentaires et je pense que
dans toute phase créative
il est important de prendre du temps
donc deux choses en une dans un premier
temps je vais faire une pause personnel
durant deux mois mais durant ces deux
mois vous aurez une vidéo sur la chaîne
tous les deux jours zyva très logique je
vous explique la en un an et demi tout
pile j'ai sorti 426 vidéo j'ai fait 200
spectacles en tournée j'ai écrit un
livre et j'ai fait des projets un petit
peu à côté bon là il est temps de
réduire un petit peu la cadence pour
retrouver de l'énergie plus de
créativité et une motivation et un peu
de temps libre pour remettre des choses
en place pour la chaîne je me laisse le
champ libre pour faire ce que j'ai à
faire prendre un petit peu de repos et
me donc meurent à organiser et commencer
à réfléchir la suite mais j'avais pas
vous laisser comme ça donc oui cet été
il y aura également une vidéo tous les
deux jours que je suis en train de faire
en ce moment pour ceux qui me suivent
depuis l'année dernière vous souvenez
que l'été dernier au mois d'août j'avais
fait une vidéo par jour sur des énigmes
cet été juillet ou tous les deux jours
les jours pairs jeu sortira une vidéo à
11 donc tous les jours pairs une vidéo à
11 heures sur la chaîne
ce seront des vidéos courtes avec
toujours un petit facteur rigolo alors
ça peut être une énigme ça peut être un
truc scientifique un peu étrange ça peut
être un truc historique un petit peu
marrante a peut être les origines de
quelque chose si vraiment c'est
intéressant
ces vidéos là seront rapides entre une
minute trente et 4 minutes brand j'en
sais rien en fait l'idée c'est de me
dire je vais pas cramé des gros sujets
cet été alors que c'est moins évident
pour vous de regarder les vidéos en plus
ce seront des vidéos fun divertissante
qui se regarde comme ça sur le pouce et
en compensation vous avez une vidéo tous
les deux jours à 11h vous savez les
jours par an other bing et une vidéo
sheholli cas ça commencera donc le 2
juillet je vous souhaite un excellent tu
étais en garde par contre le contact en
temps réel dans les commentaires sur
facebook sur instagram sur snap chad sur
twitter vous avez des liens dans la
description comme d'habitude et j'ai
hâte de vous raconter tout ce que j'ai
prévu pour la rentrée je pense que je
vous parlerai de tous à fin août
profitez bien merci d'être là vous savez
même pas à quel point je vous kiffe et à
quel point c'est un rêve déjà de vivre
tout ça avec vous et grâce à vous rendez
vous le 2 juillet ciao
[Musique]